great defense there but he's just able
to rise up and be free
with that mid-range boy has the 22 year
old answer
tonight lillard on a triple
deadly good time now starting to do it
at both ends of the floor but you see
here watch how as he comes off this
screen
jokic just caught in no man's land a lot
of dame lord and cj mccollum
the question for me is success
offensively can you get stops they're
small
are they going to double 9.8
in a three-point game lillard
telling him to get out of his way
leather not a three
[Applause]
what time is this pharaoh it is
game time as he is able to deliver there
and
put us into overtime that
i tell you what good defense that's just
much
better offense
[Applause]
jamie damian lillard with the money on
the table
they have been terrific and that really
kind of offsets
what dame has done here
lillard he'll have a chance at three
because of that three-point shot
there's so much time left you cannot get
complacent
and lose focus if you're dimmer
damian lillard on a night where he has
done
everything right
[Applause]
oh wow it just does not
get any better on his back
he has scored their last nine points
[Applause]
here he comes again lillard
steps back fires
oh my goodness get an opportunity there
and this man right here is just in his
element
when it's clutch time
damien lillard in the clutch
will take your breath away
and he is adding that again he has been
effective against jokic defensively
on the season lillard just keeps on
coming
that is denver
[Music]
look to attack but willard here
i'm going to give him the benefit of a
doubt and said he called glass james can
you just describe emotionally where
where you're at after this
tough loss man we i mean this doer died
now
so we got to win both of the next two
games if we want to if we want our
season to continue
simply that but after what you gave
just personally right it don't matter we
lost the game
so i mean at this point all that matters
is we can't lose another game in this
series so
[Music]
we go out there and we play to win the
game and uh
we came up short so uh we're going back
home it's a must win or else our season
is over
and then we got to come back here
and win on that floor again so i mean
that's what it is